hi everyone thank you for coming my name
is Alex Lev and I'm a PhD student at MIT
'z probabilistic computing projects
advised by the Cosman sinka and i'm
going to talk to you today about a style
of declarative programming called
probabilistic scripting that my friend
and colleague Monica Agarwal has been
helping to develop with me and I'm going
to expand on this quite a bit throughout
the talk but the basic idea is is this
in the past couple of decades and
especially the last five years or so
we've seen an emerging technology called
probabilistic programming really begin
to take off there's been a whole suite
of tools called probabilistic
programming languages that have been
developed and they've primarily been
aimed at making it easier to create
sophisticated statistical models and AI
research but the core insights that
power probablistic programming and the
tools themselves are more broadly
applicable than that and the idea of
this talk is to take those insights in
that technology and repurpose them a
little bit to enable a style of
declarative programming that I hope to
convince you could be useful for solving
many of the everyday problems that
software engineers face so let's look at
an example of one of those problems that
I'll be using throughout the talk which
is cleaning messy data and this headline
is reporting on a survey of data
scientists in which they reported that
cleaning the data before they got to do
the fun analysis part of the data was
their most time-consuming least
enjoyable task this is not like really
interesting work it's the sort of work
that any of us in this room could do by
hand of fixing typos recognizing that
numbers are reported in the wrong units
seeing no values that are obviously
supposed to be something and filling
them in but it's the work that has to be
done before you can actually use your
data for something that you care about
so for example this is a simplified a
cartoon example of a data set that we
might have if we're running an apartment
listings website here we only have three
columns the state the city and the sort
of rent per bedroom that this apartment
is being listed for and you can see that
this table has some null entries as some
missing entries and also if you look at
it for a minute and you're familiar with
the United States you'll also see that
there are a number of other
problems here a lot of the city names
have typos in them right they're
misspelled and if you are familiar with
the United States you can probably
pretty quickly see what we would have to
do to make this a clean data table
Beverly Hills we know is in California
Seattle is missing a tee and it's in
Washington New York is not a city in New
York State but New York is a city in New
York State
Durham my hometown in North Carolina is
D urh a.m. even though it's pronounced D
you are R um and this middle row Row 3
we can't know for sure what should go in
that cell right it could be any city in
New York but it's a pretty good bet that
it's New York City for two reasons
number one New York City is the most
populous city in New York so if we're
assuming that sort of users are coming
to our website kind of in proportion to
to the populations of those states that
would be a pretty good guess and also
how many cities in New York do you pay
$3,000 a bedroom to rent an apartment
right so humans can do a pretty good job
of cleaning this up pretty easily but
this table had five rows and if it had
5,000 rows even this whole talk wouldn't
be enough time to clean it so we want to
automate something so how do we automate
a task like this well we're in a room
full of experienced software engineers
and I can imagine many of you might be
thinking that automating this task would
actually be pretty easy we're basically
dealing with spelling correction in this
example right and maybe a table lookup
to see what state you're in and in fact
I was at MIT a couple months ago and
there was a professor who was giving a
talk on this fancy machine learning
powered data cleaning system that that
his team had built and they were using a
demo data kind of similar to this with
misspelled city names and you know zip
codes that were wrong and there was a
famous Touring Award winner in the
audience of that talk and during the Q&A
that turning Award winner stood up and
asked to paraphrase couldn't this be
solved by some pretty simple software I
assumed that he had some he was on good
terms with the speaker but you can sort
of see what he's saying it seems like a
simple script in Python or I'm gonna use
Julia it should do the trick
so let's let's put that intuition to the
test and write a script that cleans up
our toy apartment listings data set
we're
to follow a pretty simple algorithm
first we're going to loop through every
row and our goal is going to be for any
row that has a typo in the city field we
want to correct that typo and for any
row that doesn't have a state filled in
we want to fill it in so the first thing
that we can do is in each row we're
going to set the city we're going to
change the city to the nearest actual
city where nearest is comparing edit
distance or something like that of two
strings and these possible cities this
possible cities list is either going to
be every city in the United States you
know if we don't know what state it is
we can't do better than that
or if we do know the state we're going
to limit the possible cities to the
cities within that state if we are
missing the state we have to fill it in
so how are we going to fill in the state
well we're basically going to loop
through all the states and find a state
that has the city that we just inferred
was that was the true city right so
here's our here's our script let's see
what happens if we apply this script to
our data set so this was our messy data
set and when we apply the script we get
something a little bit unexpected it's
put Beverly hillz in Missouri right here
in Missouri it got Durham right go
Durham it changed New York New York to
Newark New York if you've heard of
Newark you might think it's in New
Jersey and it changed Seattle to seal it
instead of giving us the Adele
Washington it gave us seal Alabama so
what went wrong here well there it
actually didn't make any mistakes per se
there really is a Beverly Hills Missouri
not far from here in st. Louis County
it's just that it doesn't cost $4,000 to
rent a home there it cost about 800 for
a room and there really is in Newark New
York in fact there are dozens of
Newark's in the United States this
Newark has a population of about 9,000
people and it is possible that the user
really meant to type Newark New York but
it's somewhat more likely that they came
from New York which has millions of
people in it and meant to type New York
so we could say we're gonna take our
script and we're going to try to solve
this problem this is an often you know
we often debug in a cycle debugging is
an iterative process we run our script
we realize it doesn't do what we want we
go back and we change the script so we
could say let's add heuristics let's say
that when there is a tie when
two cities could possibly be the city
that we're gonna fill in we're gonna
break that tie with population size
which one has the bigger population or
we could break ties with which one has a
rent that's closer to the rents of all
the other entries that have that city in
the table right we could we could do
something like that as a heuristic but
this leads to longer harder to read
harder to maintain code especially if we
weren't using a sort of toy example here
because the people who are reading this
code weren't necessarily there when we
ran the erroneous code they might not
understand the purpose of all of this
these extra heuristics and maybe even
more importantly it doesn't tell us what
to do when our heuristics disagree with
each other I have to tie breaking rules
here well we can't use to tie breaking
rules right what if what if they
themselves create a tie so this is what
has might lead us to ask is there a
better way and one way of dealing with
this problem where your code is sort of
growing it has weird control flow it has
a lot of ifs is to turn to declarative
programming and there's already been a
talk at strange loop this year about
declarative programming the idea is that
we're going to try to say what we want
done not how to do it but there's
actually a number of flavors of
declarative programming some of you may
have heard of declarative programming in
the context of logic programming
languages and might think are you
suggesting that we use Prolog for this
problem the problem with Prolog and
other logic programming languages which
can sort of solve constraints that you
write down so you say what the
constraints you want solved are and then
it will find a logical solution is that
we don't know what logical constraints
for this problem are if we tried to
write a Prolog problem program it would
probably just have the same heuristics
but encoded declaratively instead of
imperative lis right we would say choose
the city with the closest or the correct
city is the city with the rent that is
closest to all the other city that's not
really an improvement over what we
already had another sort of
interpretation of declarative could be
and this is a little bit of a weird
interpretation is should we use neural
networks
I think of neural networks as a
declarative technology because what you
actually specified to the neural network
is your input and output examples and
then it learns how to actually do the
mapping between input and output
examples but that's also not going to
solve our problem for two reasons first
of all we need a lot of training data
for a neural net and we might not have
examples of
clean and dirty data tables right to
train this neural net but more than that
it doesn't even solve the problems that
we had which were hard to understand and
hard to maintain Google which uses a ton
of neural Nets still admitted in this in
this paper machine learning the high
interest credit card of technical debt
that machine learning is a high interest
credit card of technical debt that when
you use it it gives you short-term gains
you you get higher performance but as
the needs of your product evolve it
becomes a lot harder to maintain that
neural net in there when do you need to
retrain how do you keep track of which
data set it was trained on what have we
added a column to our data table do we
have to like completely throw away the
neural net which was trained on only
some columns right there's a lot of
questions that it raises to use neural
nets and also it really seems like we
shouldn't need to this seems like a
simple task right all of us could do it
just by by looking at a data table
there's a third kind of declarative
programming probabilistic programming
should we use that and you kind of know
by the title of the talk that my answer
is yes and the key insight is that we
can use probability theory to replace
the heuristics that we mentioned earlier
with a principled strategy for reasoning
about things that we don't know so let
me be a little bit more concrete about
that probabilistic programming relies
heavily on a formula for a probabilistic
reasoning called Bayes rule this is a
really important formula in probability
theory and statistics so much so that at
HP and Cambridge they made a neon sign
of the formula and you know that when
people make a sign for something it's
probably because it's telling us
something important but whereas this
sign it contains a logical formula if
you hit this sign then you will hit that
bridge this sign the Bayes rule sign
contains a probabilistic one telling us
how to reason about things that we don't
know by combining domain knowledge with
observations so let's take a closer look
at what it's saying there's three
letters involved in this formula an a a
B and a P so a is going to represent the
unknown variables that we're trying to
reason about B is going to represent our
observations what the what the user
actually typed in the row and P is going
to represent all of our domain knowledge
so to make this concrete let's say that
we're trying to clean this row that the
Beverly Hills $4,000 row what are our
knowns and unknowns
well it might seem that our knowns are
the city and the rent and our unknown as
the state because it's empty but
remember that we're not assuming that
the user typed the city correctly for
all we know Beverly Hills could be a
typo of Beaver Hills or Beverly right so
really we should think of this as having
two knowns and two unknowns the dirty
city the potentially dirty city and the
rent are our known things our observed
values and the unknowns are the state
and and the clean city the other letter
in this formula is P this is a
probability distribution or a model and
the idea is that it's going to encode
our domain knowledge about this data set
all of the assumptions that we bring to
the table that allow us to clean this
data set right when I was showing that
slide I said we we are familiar with the
United States we're familiar with how
cities work we know what an apartment
listings website is all of that is
knowledge that was helpful to us when we
were cleaning the data set so P is gonna
somehow have to encode that knowledge
the types of things that P is going to
have to encode involve for example the
idea that more populous cities and
states appear more often this assumption
allowed us to disambiguate between
Newark New York and New York New York
right and it tells us which values of
the unknown variables are more likely a
priori no matter what the rest of the
row says we kind of believe that cities
that are more populous are going to
appear more often there's also kind of
domain knowledge like this that per
bedroom rents in a city and state tend
to be similar across listings right and
this is what allowed us to choose
Beverly Hills California as more likely
than Beverly Hills Missouri because
Beverly Hills California had a four
thousand dollar rent that made sense
whereas Beverly Hills Missouri that
wouldn't have made as much sense and
note that this particular piece of
domain knowledge connects unknown
variables city is eight with the
observed variable rent telling us how
our observations depend on the value of
the unknown variable and that's going to
allow us to reason about which possible
unknown values actually explain our
observations better make our
observations more plausible another type
of domain knowledge that it falls into
the same category is the way that cities
and typed cities are related which is
that type cities may rarely be a typo
diversion
may really contain an edit from from the
actual city and in fact even more rarely
they may contain multiple edits right
multiple typos so we bring all of this
domain knowledge to to the problem and
some of the domain knowledge which I'm
going to denote P of a is domain
knowledge telling us which values of a
which values of our of our unknown
variables are just more or less likely
unrelated to the rest of the data right
but the other pieces of our domain
knowledge called P of B given a tell us
for a particular value of a so you
should think of that a is actually being
filled in with Beverly Hills California
or Beverly Hills Missouri right for a
particular value of a what distribution
over B does it induce what does it tell
us about which observed values would be
more likely or less likely to see given
that we're already in that we know that
we're in Beverly Hills Missouri so these
two types of information tell us what do
we expect before we even see the row
about which cities and states are going
to be likely and how should we think
about the observations that we made in
terms of how likely they would be made
by different possible hypotheses for
what the unknown values are what Bayes
rule does is give us a principled way of
combining all of these kinds of domain
knowledge with our observations it says
if you're trying to find a let's say we
have a few hypotheses for a like it
could be Beverly Hills California
or it could be Beverly Hills Missouri if
we're trying to decide what a is we
should score each of these A's according
to this formula P of B given a times P
of a it's basically multiplying how
likely is a in the first place by how
well does it explain the data B right
it's gonna allow us to trade-off between
these two components and so the rule
what we're gonna do is we're just going
to take each of our hypotheses compute
this this multiplication and see which
one is higher so in this case I haven't
told us how to give numbers to these
things yet we're going to get there how
can we actually make this quantitative
but even looking at this qualitatively
we can see that P of Beverly Hills
California has to be greater than P of
Beverly Hills Missouri because Beverly
Hills California is a more populous city
Beverly Hills Missouri has about 500
people and over here there are sort of
two things that are playing into this
there are
who observed values the typed city and
the rent now the typed City Beverly
Hills is made equally likely or is
explained equally well by both of our
hypotheses because in both of our
hypotheses Beverly Hills is the actual
city name that the person meant to type
and in both of the hypotheses zero typos
were required to get us to Beverly Hills
but the rent is explained much better by
the top row than by the bottom row and
so overall we're going to say that this
whole thing the top row is better than
the bottom row and we can choose Beverly
Hills California and this insight the
data cleaning can be framed as
probabilistic inference and application
of Bayes rule was described and made
formal in a paper just this year called
a formal framework for probabilistic
uncleaned databases but it's one thing
to recognize that probability theory
might be useful which is sort of what
we've done so far in this talk and it's
another thing to actually make it
concrete and code something up
what is the programming model that's
going to let us actually apply these
insights right we haven't even described
yet how to make these qualitative Peas
quantitative right so probabilistic
scripting is going to give us a
declarative programming framework for
applying probability theory to problems
like this in the data cleaning example
what that's going to mean is that we're
gonna want to come up with some way to
encode in a script the domain knowledge
that we have this this P then we're
gonna want to be able to feed in a messy
data set and have the cleaning happen
automatically right so we want whatever
task we're doing to happen automatically
given the domain knowledge that we've
encoded in a script and the actual
observations that we have so we're
trying to replace these heuristic
imperative scripts with probabilistic
declarative scripts that say things like
more populated cities appear more often
rents of different listings in the same
city are likely similar right so we have
to find some way of making a scripting
language that allows us to encode these
sorts of statements and before we look
at the way to do that it's worth noting
that there's reason to believe this is
sort of the right way to solve the
problem which is that if you actually go
out to organizations that have big data
cleaning needs like the Department of
Energy they have tons of data sets
coming from all over and they need to
clean all of these data sets they have
slide decks where they train lots of
humans in how to clean data and if you
look at what they say they don't say if
you see a number that is above this
threshold please divide it by a thousand
what they say is
you might see in consistent units of
measure you might see instead of
thousands of square feet which is what
we want you might see total square feet
right you might see instead of million
cubic feet you might see therms of
natural gas so it's just telling you
what sorts of data you'd expect to see
and how you might expect them to be
wrong and they're assuming that the
people will use common sense the people
who their training will use common sense
to interpret that data and use it to
sort of come up with an algorithm for
how they're actually going to clean the
data set so we need to do exactly that
we need a flexible way for users to
encode knowledge we can't just show our
computer a slide deck and we need an
efficient way to actually do the
cleaning for a computer to do the
cleaning after we convey the knowledge
and this first challenge how do we make
a scripting language for encoding domain
knowledge let's remember that this is
the kind of knowledge that we want to
encode in our script using a programming
language but not English and let's
recall that we've already seen how these
different kinds of knowledge can be
thought of as helping to specify
distributions probability distributions
telling us what values are more likely
or less likely and more concretely what
cities and states are more likely or
less likely or given a city and state
what type cities and rents are more
likely and less likely and the main
insight that we're going to borrow from
probabilistic programming is this if we
write a program that randomly generates
cities and states so imagine that this
table is just from calling a program
over and over again to randomly generate
cities and states we have implicitly
specified a distribution over cities and
states the ones that the simulator or
the generator is more likely to have
generated are more probable and the ones
that it would have that it is less
likely to have generated are less
probable so we've written down a
distribution by writing a program that
randomly generates cities and states
similarly we can write a program that
takes in a particular city in state and
randomly generates a rent and randomly
adds typos to the city to generate a
typed city and a rent and in doing that
we've specified a probability
distribution over type cities and rents
that depends on the particular city and
state that were in so in order to encode
that more
populated cities appear more often we
can randomly sample we can write a
program that randomly sampled cities
according to their populations so that
when we run it we get cities like New
York and Los Angeles much more often
than we get cities like Durham North
Carolina
so encode that rents depend on the city
we can actually randomly generate a rent
based on the city so that you know if we
do this by adding noise to some average
rent for the city rents for the same
city will cluster together and in order
to encode that city names might contain
typos we can just randomly choose some
of the city names that we generated or
you know for each city name randomly
decide to add typos or not with some
small probability so that's the idea
behind this probabilistic scripting DSL
called P clean for data cleaning that we
have what does this look like in code so
we've created a little scripting
language it's embedded in Julia and it's
specifically for writing generators
random generators of data to encode
domain knowledge and once we fill in the
blank lines here of our rent row
generator we're going to be able to call
this clean function on a table and have
it automatically clean the data and
we'll talk about how that works as well
but let's look at how the simulator
looks first so in order to say that
we're generating a value for a column we
use this @ column keyword we give the
name of the column that we're currently
generating and if we want we can give a
variable name so that we can hold on to
the value that we simulated and here I'm
just going to call this choose
proportionally function where I pass in
a list of all the states and a list of
their populations and it will choose a
state proportionally to the population
now you might be thinking right now I
listened to 20 minutes of this talk and
now you're telling me that this won't
work if I don't know the state
populations because it seems like that
would be a pretty serious limitation
once we go to the sorts of problems
where we don't necessarily have data
that we can download from the government
but we're going to get to in a minute
how we're going to relax that assumption
that we have all of this information
available for now let's focus on the
concept that if we can write this
generator we'll we'll be able to do the
cleaning so we're going to choose a
state proportionally to the populations
of the states we're going to choose a
city proportionally to the populations
of the city and notice here we're just
saying that the cities that are possible
to choose come from like a dictionary
map called cities mapping particular
states to the lists of city
that they contain right so it's going to
eat it's going to be impossible for our
script to generate a city that doesn't
belong to the state that it generated
but that's not the city that we're
actually going to see so there's also
this at dirty construct which says even
though the true city has already been
sampled now I'm going to generate a new
value which is an edited version of that
which represents the sort of way in
which it might be unclean right so we
are assuming that our city might have
typos so we're gonna call this add typos
function and if you look inside that add
typos function what it's doing is its
flipping coins with 10% probability of
heads and if it comes up tails we're
done we leave the city as it is if it
comes up heads we add a random typo to
the city a random insertion deletion or
substitution right and then once we've
added the typo we flip another coin same
coin with 10% probability of heads and
if it's another heads we add another
typo if its tail's we're done after
adding one typo so what this does is it
encodes that we think there's a 10%
probability of there being one typo a 1%
probability of there being two typos and
so on
finally we're going to sample the rent
and here I'm assuming that we have
access to this list of mean rents in all
of the cities and states in in the
United States so that what we can do is
just add some noise to it where a
hundred is the sort of an average
variation it's the standard deviation of
that noise so once we've written this
script we can run clean and it will
apply Bayes rule for us happily cleaning
our dataset no messy heuristics needed
it will incorporate all the possible
factors in making a decision it's going
to incorporate the Edit distance between
the type city and the real city because
we have that add typos in there it's
going to incorporate the plausibility of
the rent value given the city in state
and it will incorporate the populations
of the cities under consideration and we
haven't told it how to do that we
haven't written control-flow to do that
we've just told it what we know and it's
going to automatically weigh all three
of those factors to come up with an
answer but like I said there's still
something unsatisfactory about this
which is that we had to hard-code a
number of things we had to hard-code the
state populations we had to hard-code
the city populations we had to hard-code
the mean rents and we also hard-coded
this number 100 which is sort of how
much do rents
very within a city now it's worth noting
that humans actually do bring a lot of
this information to the problem right
the reason that we were able to look at
just five rows of data and clean it is
because for our whole lives we've been
learning that rents are expensive in New
York right for our whole lives where
we've been learning that what cities
exist in the United States right things
like that and which states have bigger
populations in which cities have bigger
populations so it might be unfair to
expect a computer to solve this task
without that lifelong experience but if
we can't solve the problem that sort of
fatal for this approach because many
domains don't have government datasets
telling us exactly how likely different
values of the columns are so in peak
lien we allow users to replace those
parameters with underscores and then
call this fit function to learn the
parameters from the messy data table
itself in essence the fact that we have
a big table of data can stand in for the
computers lack of life experience it can
pick up all this knowledge by looking at
patterns in the data that you give it
right and in particular the way that
this learning is actually going to work
is that it's going to begin by choosing
some initial values for all of those
parameters just setting some initial
values and then assuming that those
initial values are true it's going to
clean the data set completely then we're
going to get a completely clean data set
from which we can re estimate the
parameters and do this in a loop and
this is an algorithm called expectation
maximization and it will eventually it
should eventually converge to some
values of these parameters also notice
that these parameters these underscores
are allowed to have square brackets
after them indexing by some expression
and without saying is that a different
value of this parameter should be
learned for every value of the index
right so we're all out we're able to
then communicate that the rent per
bedroom doesn't have just one mean that
noise is added to it has a different
mean for each city and state now we're
still - you are still saying here that
we're giving it the list of cities that
exist in the list in the list of states
that exist and this might seem like a
more reasonable assumption we often do
know what the possible values for some
column are but it's kind of annoying to
compile and sometimes we don't know it
so P clean is also going to let you
replace that with an underscore and that
means that it should learn which
of the things in that column are
actually valid values and which ones
were just erroneous so for example if we
have a big data set and only one row has
the city Newport in it the system is
going to compare the hypotheses that on
the one hand it's possible that there is
a city called Newport because we haven't
told it what cities exist so it's
possible that there is a city called
Newport but if that were the case it
would have such a small population that
only one entry from this table came from
it and so then it's comparing the
probability that we got the one citizen
of Newport versus the possibility that
one of the millions of citizens from New
York made a typo right and so it's going
to correct it to New York on the other
hand if we have several rows called
Newport and the rents are very low now
the calculus kind of changes because on
the one hand it can consider the
possibility that all of these people
made this typo same typo and that they
somehow all happen to be the ones who
got the cheapest rents in New York or it
can consider that there actually is a
small city called Newport in New York
that has cheap rents right and in this
case it will prefer the second
hypothesis and none of this came from us
explicitly coding these heuristics in
pea clean is based on probability theory
which is the lingua franca of a lot of
research in data science so I want to
show you one School benefit that we get
kind of for free by using probability
theory here which is that we can benefit
from some of the latest advances in AI
to create more expressive models so I
don't know if you've seen it was in the
news a while back that open a I had it
rained this huge language model called
GPT to GPT - they said it was so good at
generating language that it would be
dangerous for them to release it to the
world so they've been going on this like
small release strategy where they
released slowly more accurate models so
this is based on one of the medium
models that they've released what I'm
going to show you and the idea is that
you can prompt this this neural network
with a string it can be a pretty long
string so here I've put the abstract of
this talk ending within this talk I'll
introduce okay and it's going to
complete that string for us using what
it's learned from billions of documents
over the web so it chooses to say in
this talk I'll introduce X table which
enables Commons
reasoning to code up automated fixes and
checklists who automate common errors
and get your data clean faster don't
worry it includes a free demo I don't
appreciate it making promises on my
behalf but the idea is that that since
this is actually just all based on
probability theory all of these numbers
that we need in order to add one of
these primitive distributions are
available to us from GPT too so we can
add a new distribution called GPT to
elaborate a new primitive that we can
use in our models that's going to take
in a prompt and return and a completion
an elaboration of that of that string
according to GPT - this allows us to
model new date new kinds of datasets so
here's a data set of reviews it has
three columns whether a review is
positive what the product type being
reviewed is and the actual text of
review and these are actual Amazon
reviews and you can see some of the
cells are missing so what we can do is
we can write a pea clean script that
says okay here's how the data is
generated first we flip a coin I don't
know what the weight is to determine
whether we're gonna write a positive or
negative review and I don't know the
weight because maybe people are more
positive or more negative in general as
a whole let's not assume anything by
writing point five or something like
that then we're going to choose a
product type and you will just learn
what product types exist by looking at
the table itself and we'll learn what
proportion they occur in and then we
somehow want to say write or review that
that's based on is positive and the
product type and the idea is that we're
going to use GPT to elaborate on some
prompt to do that we're going to prompt
GPT - we could use the prompt the
following is my review and then just
have GPT to write a review but then GPT
twos review will not be based on the
sentiment and the product type that we
just sampled right there's no
relationship between these two so we
could instead say the following is my
review of this book or of this movie or
of this app and that's going to make it
more likely to generate reviews that are
about the product but we want to
incorporate the sentiment too so we can
switch on the sentiment with an if
statement and say if the if we're trying
to generate a positive review we're
going to prompt it by saying I'm giving
this book a very positive review because
it's fantastic a plus five out of five
best book ever like and otherwise we're
gonna say I'm giving this book a very
bad review because it's awful
one out of five truly terrible worst
book ever like and then we're gonna pass
that to GPT - to finish off the review
okay once we've done that once we've
included our assumptions about how the
review text depends on the other columns
right P clean can figure out that this
was a positive review about a book or a
negative review about a movie and we
didn't have to do any additional
training we didn't have to train a
neural net with a bunch of labeled
examples all of all we had to do was
specify the task by writing up this
prompt and and writing up this script so
I said there were two challenges we've
looked at the first challenge the second
one I'm going to spend less time on
because I've got just I want to spend
another five minutes or so this this
task look that I'm calling cleaning in
this example more generally is called
probabilistic inference it's about how
you infer the values of unknown
variables given domain knowledge and
your known variables and it's one of the
things that probabilistic programming
languages give us a lot of tools to do
so the architecture of PE and how it
actually works is that we take this
script that the user has written and we
compile it into a probabilistic model in
a general-purpose probabilistic
programming language called gen and
we're also going to extract some
metadata from this script that gen
wouldn't know about because they're sort
of things that are specific to two data
cleaning so we're going to extract from
the script sort of what fields are clean
what fields have the possibility of
being dirty which fields have parameters
which were these underscores what our
initial parameter values are we're going
to infer sort of there's also stuff that
I haven't shown about missingness we're
going to get metadata about sort of
aspects of the parameter estimation
process because none of that is sort of
built into gen but what we get by having
this probabilistic model represented in
gen is that it gives us the ability to
evaluate probabilities to express the
operation of conditioning our simulator
unknown observed values and most
importantly it gives us a library of
building blocks for approximate
inference and this is something that
couldn't have been done until very
recently because for a long time
probably stick programming languages
were just push button just like peek
Lina's you specify your model you say
clean and you hope that the algorithm
say infer and you hope
the algorithm can handle your model
right in djenne instead it gives us a
library of building blocks where we can
construct our own inference algorithm
and the inference algorithm behind peak
lien is making use of that we're using
several of the building blocks together
to create an inference program that
combines sequential Monte Carlo and
expectation-maximization by using these
building blocks it's something that Jenn
calls programmable inference and there
was another talk at strange Luke
yesterday by my colleague Marco about
that so feel free to go online and look
it explains sort of the new programming
constructs that enable the expression of
these kinds of inference algorithms the
nice thing about peak lean and in
general I hope about sort of these
domain-specific probabilistic
programming languages is that once
you've restricted yourself to a certain
domain you can reason much more
effectively about what sorts of
inference algorithms will always work in
that domain and so the idea is that this
inference algorithm though I'm sure that
we still need to work on it's um
it should be applicable to most of the
models that people write in Pete clean
because Pete clean isn't quite as
expressive as Jenn as a whole right we
have some preliminary results very
preliminary results sort of showing that
these existing machine learning based
systems for data cleaning we can match
them if we just encode some basic domain
knowledge and into our scripts but I
want to zoom out a little bit at the
very end because my point today isn't
primarily about pee clean or data
cleaning
it's about this broader idea of
probabilistic scripting the basic point
is that if you have some code that's
imperative and relies on a bunch of
heuristics right it's often because
you're trying to do something common
sense that the computer doesn't have the
declarative knowledge in order to solve
right that's what's getting you into
this mess and if you can frame your task
as reasoning about unknown variables in
the context of domain knowledge and
observed variables then we can think
about actually replacing this with a
much more natural sort of scripting
approach where you just tell it what you
assume to be true and your normal
computer would say what am I supposed to
do with that but we have replaced it
with a robot that has read a probability
theory textbook by which I mean we have
replaced it with a robot that whose
internals are to compile into one of
these powerful general-purpose
probabilistic programming languages get
some meta data out and then run an
inference program and the idea is that
this should work whenever you can frame
your problem as an inference task with
domain knowledge unknown variables and
observed values so if that sounds
appealing to you I encourage you to play
around with Jen yourself and help invent
new probabilistic scripting languages
the language is open-source and embedded
in Julia and in addition to the API
documentation we have a number of
tutorials available in this Jen
QuickStart repository and I want to
thank all the members of the prop Comp
team this wouldn't have been possible
without them I also want to thank
strange loop for holding this awesome
event and letting me come here and share
this with you and also this project is
funded in part by the Facebook
probability and programming research
award so I want to thank them thanks
[Applause]